let's go to our caller from the eight
one five area code caller from eight one
five who's this where are you calling
from
hi this is Jonathan I'm from Rockford
Illinois hey Jonathan what's on your
mind
good so my question a bit of a
two-parter but I think I'll just has the
first part in case um so for last
election in 2016 you know the hot issue
I think most people agree with the
immigration this year for 2020 but
coming up 2020 more or less going to be
probably single-payer health care and
you know obviously Donald Trump and so
my question is a little bit you know for
20 it's never - I guess early for
politicians to look too ahead so for
like 2024 you know it's just the nature
of the political piece people are
already probably trying to you know plan
their way up out there and so for me I
was wondering in your opinion this year
its health care which was brought by
Bernie I'm Andrew yang bringing up you
know ubi
do you think that would be the next hot
issue for just any platform in 2024 or
do you think it'd be some other issue
that you maybe you think is not being
you know covered as much listen I can't
even tell you what the main issues are
going to be within the Democratic
primary debates in six months or
whenever it is that they start so I
wouldn't even venture a guess as to what
are going to be the issues of 2024 I
think big picture what you're going to
see is that as the sort of crisis of
inequality and wages and employment and
technological technological automation
deepens you are going to see more and
more focus on what is your plan to deal
with the changing status quo of our
relationship to work and this includes
everything from wages wealth inequality
taxation would fall under that because
of its economic impact health care is
also going to be a discussion there so
if I had to pick an umbrella that's
where it would be also being aware of
the fact that as the climate change
crisis gets worse and worse it will be
sort of unavoidable that that also
becomes prevalent but as far as
24 or the 2022 midterms I just don't
know I think it's just way too early to
know okay yeah definitely
um and so do you think I'm still like I
said before Bernie was kind of like you
know though the dark horse for the last
election do you think in this election
you know someone like Andrew Young
anti-gang who's bringing um you know you
be I hope to you know a platform do you
think you might be someone that you know
people might latch on to just as they
did in burning but I mean I think that
it would be fascinating if Andrew yang
did get that surge in support his
fundraising is going pretty well he's
getting more and more media interviews
he's one of my top three so I hope that
that does happen and that he has a more
prominent voice in the 2020 Democratic
primary for sure okay well those are all
my questions so thank you for answering
all right thank you so much for the call
I appreciate it let's go to a break if
you are holding I'm sorry I wasn't able
to get to you but there are like 40
people holding and we will take more
calls next week and I look forward to
hearing from more people